a very interesting new study finds that
Americans on average die younger in
conservative and red States now this
won't be a surprise to some of you who
know some of the underlying data here
but let's start with the study as
reported by the guardian more liberal
policies on environment gun safety labor
economic taxes and tobacco taxes
associated with lower mortality the
authors of the study write
simulations indicate that changing all
policy domains in all states to a fully
liberal orientation could have saved
over a hundred and seventy one thousand
lives in 2019 changing to a fully
conservative orientation could cost more
than 217 000 lives the study was
published in plus plus one plus one plos
one I always forget how it's pronounced
which is a science journal the authors
are from Syracuse Syracuse University
Harvard VCU University of Washington
University of Texas at Austin and
University of Western Ontario Canada
I have to tell you this really isn't
surprising there is a very interesting
metric and when we talk about the United
States sometimes it said well the United
States could really be divvied up
into
six different regions that would be as
big as many European countries or 12
different regions I have seen there is a
metric called the human development
index this metric takes into account
health education income and life
expectancy to give us a number
essentially below zero and one one being
very high and zero being very low and
when you look around the world you see
maybe not like a hugely surprising list
of countries at the top of the list so
for example countries with a very very
high HDI human development index
Switzerland Norway Iceland Hong Kong
Australia no real surprises there
right there with them Denmark Sweden
Ireland Germany Netherlands Finland
Singapore Belgium New Zealand Canada you
start to see Trends in the types of
places that these are you can assign
values just like you can to a country to
a state and one of the things that you
will see which are totally separate from
this study that we're talking about here
is that the states with the highest hdis
also are overwhelmingly blue States
you've got at the top Massachusetts
Connecticut Minnesota New Jersey New
Hampshire Colorado DC North Dakota
Washington Hawaii New York Maryland
Vermont so we are
13 14 in
with one red State and one purple State
of New Hampshire
this is not new information to many of
us now what's an important question in
general is the life expectancy
specifically
do they die younger because they're
poorer and they're poorer due to
Republican economic policy or do they
die younger because of the direct effect
of Republican social and other policy
the answer pretty clearly seems to be a
sort of all of the above type of thing
uh going back to the article a little
bit
especially strong associations were
observed between certain domains and
specific causes of death between gun
safety and suicide mortality among men
between labor and alcohol-induced
mortality between both the economic tax
and tobacco tax and cardiovascular
mortality
um very very interesting and the study
authors also note that American life
expectancy as a whole is lower than most
high income countries falling between
Cuba and Albania
one of the things that sometimes will
come up on the show
is I want to move to a country with a
much higher standard of living
and one of the things to understand is
that a lot of times the folks saying
that are in states with low standards of
living it's difficult to move to a lot
of the countries on the list I showed
you but it's much easier relatively it's
not free there's still costs and
sometimes those states are more
expensive you can much more easily move
to a state in the U.S with an equivalent
standard of living too many of those
European countries because the United
States is so stratified and the
difference between Massachusetts and
Mississippi
on every indicator could not be more
different so interesting study not
surprising information but interesting
to see it laid out so cleanly in terms
of the data we'll link to the study so
you can take a look at it for yourselves
you might remember last week I told you
that Lara Logan formerly of 60 minutes
she is a
um she is now a right-wing conspiracy
nut I hate to use such titillating and
profess talkative language but that is
what she is she appeared on Newsmax I
played the clip for you she delivered a
completely unhinged xenophobic rant
essentially her version of white
replacement Theory or great replacement
Theory she was banned from Newsmax okay
instead of rethinking some of her ideas
and saying maybe I was wrong on some of
this stuff I don't know she appeared on
the absolute truth on Lindell TV
with an even crazier conspiracy theory
about children
listen to this
he said I believe that people
people think is where are all the
missing children what happens to these
children how can hundreds of thousands
of kids go missing in the United States
every year and nobody knows where they
are they just vanish I don't think so
every sex trafficking ring worldwide
knows bring the kids to the United
States that this Administration is
participating in the trafficking of kids
because they're paying uh companies
llc's and non-profits and church groups
they're paying them to take these kids
and disappear them including the report
that you showed have talked about the
blood of young children being the secret
to anti-aging you guys are you you know
what she just said right
ingesting or injecting the blood of
young young children as an anti-aging
mechanism
how do you get the blood of young
children and does it matter if the
children are younger and younger and
younger so now you're talking are you
talking about the blood of babies now no
no one's talking about that Lara you
know at this point it genuinely seems
like this is someone who
should be more on the mental health
treatment side than the delivering
opinion publicly side
you got banned from Newsmax Newsmax is
insane and what you said was too crazy
for Newsmax
uh it's time to maybe rethink some of
your views but unfortunately and I'm not
even kidding this is kind of sad because
at one point Lara Logan
did some reasonably good journalistic
reporting
um she is completely off the deep end in
every way and I feel bad for her to some
degree but at the end of the rainbow for
lack of a better term I want to have
compassion and I you know all these
different things at the end of the
rainbow there are so many people in the
United States
so delusional and depraved that even
this stuff they hear and they believe I
mean who would have thought Q Anon
beliefs could invade one-fifth of the
Republican party as we learned in a
recent poll and so my instinct is
empathy and uh you know saying this is
someone who's in in a crisis she needs
support Etc and also extremely dangerous
because of the things that she is saying
which get followers no matter how crazy
they are my friends subscribe to the
YouTube channel we are doing our very
best to get to 2 million subscribers
we're at about 1.55 now we don't even
need any new viewers to get to 2 million
because I learned that last month
4.3 million different people watched
videos on our YouTube channel and yet
only 1.5 million were subscribers we
already have nearly 3 million additional
viewers they already watch the content
some of them even like it although some
don't if just a fraction of you fine
folks who watch but don't subscribe hit
that subscribe button on YouTube we
could get to 2 million overnight do the
thing youtube.com the davidpackman show
we're going to take maybe the shortest
break in history and be right back with
much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course a
program supported by our audience we
don't have some big Media Company
backing us we don't have regardless of
what people email in and say some rich
guy funding the show we're primarily
funded by you and you can sign up at
joinpakman.com get a membership get the
bonus show get the daily commercial free
audio and video feeds and the exclusive
invites to the members only Town Halls
get all of it and you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get an absolutely
perfect discount let's go to the Discord
Lines phone lines call them what you
want
let's hear from the people in the
audience at the end of the day the most
important people to the show
uh davidpackman.com Discord is where you
can find the Discord and let's start
today with Diego from Jacksonville
Florida Diego welcome what's on your
mind today
Diego welcome what is on your mind today
and Diego is gone let's go next to Paul
from St Louis Paul from St Louis welcome
to the program
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
fine my friend beautiful
um so I had a quick comment about your
interview with Mike Lindell I know we've
beaten this to death already sure
um but
I showed that interview to a friend of
mine and he insisted that Mike Lindell
instead of being just unable to come up
with his own thoughts uh and trying to
like get these numbers from uh what was
it Minnesota Wisconsin I think in the
interview I did with him yeah
yeah so instead of
um that he's just being dishonest and I
said I don't know I feel like he really
is a True Believer and believes what
he's saying
um but what I would like to see if you
actually do interview him again in the
future yeah uh is communicate with him
ahead of time listen I might ask you
about this I would like to I'd like for
you to have those numbers in front of
you
um so that we can actually discuss and
like really drill down into what these
numbers are telling us in a practical
sense it's basically impossible the the
community so that would make sense like
in a logical planet where the
communication with him and his team
makes sense but based on the way that
these interviews get booked and what the
communications like that is an
impossibility it's not an unreasonable
suggestion you're making a completely
reasonable suggestion it'll just never
happen the way that it's it's a miracle
he even ends up in front of the camera
at the time roughly at the time we've
agreed on
uh yeah I I think that is very fair uh I
do think that in that interview he was
the most Lucid I think I've ever seen
him
well you know I I you're right in a
sense but there's a question of okay he
sounds articulate and Lucid but at the
same time if he's literally just making
the things up as he goes along it's not
particularly it's not real Lucidity and
if he's delusionally believing these
things that's also not really Lucid I
think what you mean is he just sounded
coherent yes that's exactly what I mean
right right no I agree with you he did
sound more coherent although the things
coming out of his mouth made no sense
uh okay one more quick question is there
um a time slot that you are booking for
him or is it his people telling you okay
this is how much time that he has
so I was I our producer Pat handled the
logistics if I recall correctly the
interview was roughly at the normal time
we propose so I I it seems to me that we
kind of proposed the time and he agreed
to it okay yeah because I was wondering
if there's a way to like you know
instead of like really just let him
find those numbers and just sit there
until he
comes up with them you know yeah I mean
you're everything you're saying makes
sense it's just like when you're
actually producing a show it things
don't necessarily work out where that
that's plausible
sure okay well that's all I had David
all right my friend thank you very much
yeah no a lot of people with a lot of
questions about the logistics of the uh
pillow interview and others
um okay we are taking calls through
Discord remember if you want even a
chance of getting on your nickname has
to have your name and where you're
calling in from so I see folks with
nicknames or no location or or you know
inside jokes or whatever you won't get
called on unless you have the proper
delineation like for example Jess from
Oregon Jess from Oregon you were able to
figure out how to correctly set up your
nickname and now you're on the show
oh wonderful
um I uh wanted to ask you about the uh
have you seen uh these environmental
protests like environmentalist
protesters who have been throwing food
on uh paintings and then gluing their
hand to the wall yes I have
okay my question for you is uh as a you
know we're we're both pretty young
people who care about the Earth
does this do anything is this giving
um attention to is this like calling
attention to the right people is this I
don't think so Jess I think that this is
a terribly misguided form of protest now
one of the arguments that's made is but
listen David now you and Jess are
talking about it yes we're talking about
it but the context isn't that the
attempted destruction of a van Gogh
painting has now made Jess and I start
donating to end world hunger right we're
talking about it as wow this is really
misguided now I am sympathetic to the
view that if you only do protests in the
ways that everybody agrees you should do
them you will achieve nothing in many
cases it's it's understood that
sometimes you've got to make people a
little uncomfortable or you've gotta
kind of insert yourself into a situation
but destroying artwork Priceless artwork
historically significant artwork to make
the case that we should be focused on
the climate or on hunger or whatever
I don't think is actually achieving that
and if you look at the conversations
about these attempts to to you know
throw the paint and all this other stuff
it's mentioned that oh and it was
because of hunger but nobody goes wow
that's really what our focus should be
let's go donate to end Hunger people go
this is the wrong way to go about it the
the motivation becomes not even
secondary it becomes almost irrelevant
and there I don't believe they're
achieving anything at all yeah I think
it's um it's it's uh I'm sorry it is
creating a spectacle instead of creating
something thought-provoking right right
all right well thank you very much for
your input thank you Jess everything
good in Oregon there
no it's I mean it's Smoky
all right well appreciate hearing from
you
thanks so much all right there goes Jess
from Oregon bringing up a very important
issue
let's go next to
uh why don't we go now to Jet is it Jess
or Jesse from North Carolina it's kind
of cut off
uh Josiah as a matter of fact Josiah
welcome Josiah I appreciate it David hey
I got a question especially in light of
the last night's debate between Oz and
fetterman yes earlier this week right or
was it not last night well you know
we're it's Friday today it's Friday
today true touche uh I got thinking
about you know we're seeing obviously
the the polls change uh to the detriment
of Democrats you've been commenting on
this on your shows and I keep going back
to the double standards to which I feel
that Democrats are held to not just by
conservatives but also by Centrist
moderates and people on the left in
terms of performance and substance and I
was on Twitter and I was seeing like all
the headlines
um from people who would be considered
quote unquote uh liberal or mainstream
journalists which are perceived to have
a liberal bias and they were ravaging
fetterman for his performance even know
you know his communication issues as far
as we know are just it's temporary
Aphasia it's a stroke-induced speech
impediment yeah I don't know how
temporary it is to be totally honest but
it's not cognitive I mean he remembered
all the facts he remembered all the
points he understood his position and
those of Mehmet Oz I don't know if it's
temporary but it's certainly it's only a
speech thing that's absolutely the case
and fair enough it may it may very well
not be transient but I got thinking
about it and I'm like the GOP has been
fielding and successfully electing
terrible communicators who as far as we
know don't have a medical basis like W
bush and Palin and Trump and gosar and
green why is it that everybody not just
conservatives but everybody seems to
hold Democrats to a higher standard of
performance and style and substance in
terms of politicking and messaging and
debate and is there anything that we can
do as people who want Democrats to take
power to stop contributing to that
double standard I don't know what we can
do to stop contributing to it you know
you're asking me why because because
they're Hypocrites right I don't know
how to answer it anymore clearly you
know Herschel Walker as far as we know
didn't have a stroke it's not been
acknowledged that he has CTE from
playing football and he makes less sense
than fetterman right fetterman had a
speech issue but he at least
communicated policy and understands the
issues and stuck to the issue that was
being discussed etc etc they say
fettermen should have dropped out blah
blah blah
and they say any criticism of Herschel
Walker is racism for example or
something like that right I I don't know
what we can do to stop them being
Hypocrites but that's fundamentally what
this is do you agree though see because
I I guess I don't see it just as an US
versus them I feel that that people who
would nominally be considered quote
unquote liberal or quote unquote you
know like like there's the perception
that the the mainstream media that the
New York Times the CNN yeah has a
liberal bias and I probably agree that
most New York Times and CNN journalists
I would expect would vote Democrat but
they I feel hold Democrats to hire
performative and substantive standards
than Republicans as well because again
if if the metric is this person's a poor
Communicator therefore they should drop
out of the race then who on Earth could
the Republican party ever field the NW
Bush Palin Trump so so do you I guess do
you agree that it's not just
conservatives holding Democrats to a
higher standard I do agree I do agree
and part of it is I mean it's a good
thing that we have higher standards
right Trump would never have won the
Democratic Primary in 2016. he won the
Republican primary because we have
higher higher standards than they do and
that's a good thing in a lot of cases it
starts to become not so good if it
contributes to more of these right-wing
lunatics getting elected
I agree okay well I I appreciate it I'm
glad at least we there's some sort of
consensus and I appreciate your coverage
on all this keep going thank you so much
very much appreciate the call let's go
to Dylan from Tijuana Dylan welcome
foreign
can I tell you something that drives me
nuts about how Americans pronounce the
name of the of the city you're in
oh my God me too yeah they say oh you
know I went from San Diego to Tijuana
and I'm like oh first of all no no where
is where are you getting some of these
additional syllables it doesn't make any
sense Tia like the word for aunt
um it's Tijuana that's it guys please
yeah I know all right Dylan go ahead
please I'm sorry
my uh my question for you is uh how
screwed do you think uh do you think
people are in the Colorado River Basin
like La Las Vegas Phoenix San Diego
Tijuana for water scarcity in the future
oh uh listen here's the thing about it
I don't want to okay let's see how can I
how can I back this up one of the things
that sometimes happens in any kind of
climate change discussion
is people will start to say Hey listen I
agree there's a problem I agree if
nothing changes it'll be a disaster but
I'm confident that engineering and
Ingenuity will figure out a solution
before it really becomes a problem and I
think that that's very very dangerous
thinking because we should be trying to
figure things out but we should also be
changing our behavior and our
consumption and all these different
things
on the issue of water
I actually am more confident that
science and technology is going to
figure out a solution in that part of
the country but I still think that water
usage and water rights which are a
really controversial thing in California
and in that area need to be kind of
rethought from the ground up anyway even
though based on what I'm reading about
water technology it's probably all going
to work out okay although there may be
irreversible changes to the fertility of
certain parts of those States as climate
changes and water becomes more scarce
not drinking water but but sort of
groundwater is as the the case may be so
that's that's a really complicated issue
yeah and here in Tijuana we've uh it's
happened a couple of times this year and
several times last year where we'll have
tens of thousands of people without
water because they're making repairs to
the to the water line supposedly
for you know better efficiency and you
know better management stuff like that
but
then I go out and drive in the streets
of Tijuana there's just these large
leaks just you know roads are wet in the
middle of a sunny day because yeah
so uh I I as a consumer in General on
these climate change things I'm tired of
being blamed for my individual choices
when it's the large government
authorities and large industries that
are really really messing up it's like
the thing about straws you know and it's
like wait hold on a second let's back up
a little bit or you know I took a seven
instead of a five minute shower but look
at the almond and avocado Growers and
how they're you know using ungodly
amounts of water yeah no I totally know
what you mean the drops in the bucket
exactly right well yeah I really
appreciate you uh coming down coming
down to our side of the border and uh if
you're ever in Tijuana hit me up yeah so
like what are the what are the best
tacos in Tijuana
the tacos you're eating at the time oh
okay like they're all good they're all
good anyway yeah I will say one thing uh
in Tijuana we have a light Regional
variation on some uh Adobe
in Tijuana means something different
from the rest of the country the rest of
the country and the U.S we'll call it al
pastor but we have our own little kind
of twist Regional Twist on it so I
highly recommend Alabama that's that's a
fair recommendation have you had
Americans go down and and ask about
tacos have you heard that pronunciation
before
uh you just like asking the critters
don't you David yeah yeah yeah I've
heard everything yeah yeah no I re the
other day A friend of mine said tacos
and I was like what is happening yeah
anyway all right well thank you for the
call I appreciate it
all right let's take a very very short
break if you're holding
stay on because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
speak to a few more people
davidpackman.com Discord is the place to
do it let's go to Sammy in New York City
Sammy what's going on
Sammy in New York City please unmute
yourself you have self-muted and that is
why no one can hear you you are on the
air but you have muted yourself Sammy
and if you unmute yourself yes can you
hear me yes oh my God finally I got
through
um David quick question and you might
have already answered this in another uh
podcast and I'd love your show by the
way thank you um
if um
Mike Pence had said it had agreed with
Donald Trump and said hey you know what
I am going to stop the election uh of
Biden what would have hit like what
would that process have been like I mean
I know he couldn't but like he's like
okay yeah I'm gonna do it yeah this is a
very good question
I can't say that I can tell you for
certain
exactly what the sequence would have
been if Pence did try to stop the
election from being certified right I
don't believe he ultimately would have
succeeded but I think it would have been
very dangerous and it probably would
have been something like
Pence would say in certain States like
when they get to Arizona saying we give
our votes to Biden parents would have
said something like
you know due to the controversy
outstanding and
I am not going to accept those electoral
votes
if he wanted to go further he could have
said I'm going to recognize an alternate
slate of electors and that would have
probably become a constitutional crisis
if he simply rejected to accept some my
understanding is that it just lowers the
total number
and it lowers the number you need to be
president from 270 to something lower
and by will probably still becomes
president but with people but the point
is it would have been extremely
dangerous and it would have been a
perilous moment for our democracy
right and obviously he couldn't have
carried it out anyway I agree he's been
such a Trump's like you know of his
yeah the whole while so I'm just was
curious about that and David I'm so
excited to talk to you like I watch you
every day yes thank you so amazing I
appreciate that yes absolutely and you
know good luck to your family
um and um I'm I'm I'm just blown away at
how amazingly informative you are I love
you I really appreciate that I'm sure
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
a thousand percent I knew I had a
feeling Sammy that you're
I am all right thank you so much for the
call I appreciate it my pleasure have a
good day Sammy from the city great great
stuff let's go next to Ricky from
Charlotte Ricky from Charlotte welcome
to the program
hey David uh I just uh joined the call
log so I didn't hear the earlier
questions but has anyone already asked
about the the fetterman Oz debate well
it what was brought up the only thing
that's been brought up so far about Oz
fetterman earlier this week was that the
left just seems to have higher standards
for candidates sometimes to our own uh
deficit that that was really the only
angle so far
okay well I guess the the main thing I
was getting at was Hal was trying to get
an idea of how damaging you think this
could be for fetterman
um and I I know that like it probably
remains to be seen I was trying to like
look at other campaigns that have had
like you know things that in theory
should have been disastrous but some
candidates still ended up performing
better yeah
um I don't know if you uh saw back in
2018 there was a
um there's a famous brothel owner in
Nevada who was running for election he
was like a big friend of Donald Trump I
remember that I don't remember the guy's
name but I remember Dennis Hoffman he
died he died two weeks before his
election and he still won by like a two
to one margin right
um and so you know I feel like you know
dying has got to be like worse than like
just having
um
so here's my sense of this you're right
I don't know what the effect is going to
be yet the the issue what what really is
disappointing about this is
fetterman's not having a cognitive issue
it was very clear during the debate
he knew Oz's positions on things
he knew uh what Oz had said about
different things he was having an issue
converting thoughts into speech and it's
not as though this would in any way
limit his ability to be a senator his
doctors have cleared him for full
senatorial Duty and because it's so
close it's a one point right now with
the polling we have it's 1.3 points by
which fetterman is winning
you may end up with Senator Oz because
fetterman had a stroke and that's just
so disturbing
so you think there are probably some
enough undecided left that would be
willing to flip their vote I'm not
saying there are I'm not saying there
are but I'm saying it's so close that
even if the number is really small it
could flip the election I don't think
it's a large number of people it's just
so close
okay and I guess so the last thing on
this is uh what do you think fetterman
could do from here like the last two
weeks to turn this around I don't think
there's anything I think it's just it's
the ground game and I don't I don't know
that fetterman publicly doing stuff is
what he needs I think it's just he's got
to have a better ground game get out the
vote put on repeat the fact that Oz said
local politicians should be involved in
making decisions about abortions and
hope that that is enough
do you think what if you did like a
press conference with like a physician
or something like that and and he was
able to speak more clearly or the yeah
it's got to go really well and so he's
got to be sure it's gonna go so well
that it will convince people and I just
don't know I just don't know yeah
okay yeah
um it's a frustrating situation I agree
with you yeah okay cool all right well
thanks for taking my call me all right
thanks very much there's Ricky from
Charlotte raising a very important
questions that's for sure let's go to
Ann in Wisconsin another uh critical
state in this election and welcome to
the program
hi
um glad that I got through
um
so
I am looking at the macro picture of
kind of American politics right now and
I am kind of scared
of the overall
let's say Nazi iization
of the Republican party
and I think you've talked about it and
the increasing anti-Semitism yes
that is taking over and from my
perspective
being one of those letters in the LGBT
it is terrifying because I think what
gets overlooked
is that the Nazis are the reason that
um our Research into
um
LGBT health is not where it should be we
are years and years behind because
um one of the Pioneers I believe his
name is hirschfeldt
um all of his research was burned by the
Nazis
so
um
and so it it and this is relevant
because the question of the Supreme
Court overturning
gay marriage is kind of up in the air
right now yes and to me this just
screams holy [ __ ] we're going down Nazi
land
and that's horrified it would be better
if you didn't swear because we have to
bleep that I also I apologize did you
have a question today Anne yes
yes
um do you have an overall
um
sense that that's the direction
that we're going
or do you think that's a fringe do you
think that's going to become a majority
of the party majority I don't know but
it's been made abundantly clear
that they're not stopping with their
Victory on Roe v Wade you don't have
your biggest Victory and then say I'm
done I mean okay Michael Jordan retired
at the top after three but then he came
back and he won some more and then you
know okay the point is it's they're not
going to just call it quits after one of
their biggest victories in decades
they've said they believe that the gay
marriage decision was wrongly decided in
the same way that they believe Roe v
Wade was wrongly decided so they're
coming for it the question is will they
succeed
and I don't know the answer to that one
thing that scares me Anne is that if you
look at recent right-wing in-person
events like for example CPAC a few
months ago the biggest Applause lines
were the anti-lgbt
um comments and it happened with Ted
Cruz on pronouns and it happened with
Trump and so it does seem that there is
a Resurgence of anti-lgbt sentiment
within the Republican Party
right and
my take on that and I don't know if you
agree is that none of them care about
that it's just Mass hysteria who doesn't
care in what sense Republicans
they don't I don't think they really
care about the gay marriage or the the
pronouns oh I I think they do but I
think they care about it
more broadly about what they feel it
means for the direction of the country
and less about individual LGBT people
that I would agree with okay because I
think I I don't know I just think are
they going to use this kind of
rhetoric because I I honestly think that
they're going to go Nazi
just flat out well I I don't know let's
hope that doesn't happen but in the in
the immediate we have some very
important votes coming up just two weeks
from now so I know you'll be voting Anne
and I really appreciate the call
all right thank you so much for having
me on sorry for the swears no problem
very very important stuff and I
appreciate that let's go to the state of
Georgia I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly is it Hannah is that the right
pronunciation
yeah sorry Hi
um it's uh Hannah it's just spelled
weird because my uh Mom's family is from
the Netherlands oh okay um but yeah so
sorry I'm super nervous you're doing
great so Georgia like I was uh I wasn't
born here but I grew up here like even
when I moved in high school I came back
here for college and to be with my
family and friends and like just the
right like the rate they're going like
I'm like as a person able to get
pregnant and a like a mother of a
daughter I'm honestly petrified to stay
in Georgia or really even the U.S if it
keeps going down the route we're going
um and so like but I'm sure like I have
like an idealized version of other
countries
so like I was just wondering like are
there any countries that you're like
confident in
like their you know level of Education
the government regulation yeah like
standard of living things like that and
then I did have one other question so
listen here here's the thing there's a
um a metric called the human development
index okay and I hear you saying you
know you're worried about Georgia but
maybe you're worried about the entire
U.S I do think it's important to
understand that in the U.S if you search
for U.S states ranked by HDI you will
find
that at the top of the list you have
Massachusetts Connecticut Minnesota New
Jersey New Hampshire Colorado these are
states whose HDI is equivalent to that
of places like Switzerland Norway
Iceland Hong Kong Australia Denmark
Sweden
and those are all very good places to be
human development index is basically a
kind of like a blended metric that takes
into account life expectancy education
income health a bunch of it's like a
blended metric those States I mentioned
and really everything from like you know
roughly like Oregon and up which is like
you know about 18 states or so it's not
that different than some of the best
places in the world to live the problem
is that at the bottom of the list it
gets very bad right and it's mostly red
States it's Mississippi West Virginia
Alabama Arkansas Kentucky Louisiana
South Carolina Tennessee Oklahoma you
get the picture George is down there as
well things are much much worse so one
thing is it's hard to move to other
countries so I would look at is there a
state you can move to where abortion
rights are safe education is better
Access to Health Care is better and the
answer is there are many such States if
you want to look internationally then
you're looking at some of the countries
I just mentioned but it's quite
difficult to move to some of those
places
yeah well I think I just worry more
about like not even just like down to
the particular States but like what
they're coming after a national level I
understand I understand the truth is
even with that there are many states in
which you are protected against a lot of
those things not all of them certainly
Social Security you're not going to be
protected no matter what state you're in
if they gut it but uh you know it you
don't have to run away screaming just
just yet I'll tell you if the time comes
for that
from Democrats
sure
um so like would trying to like I know
that obviously they've like a lot of
them have very confused moral compasses
yes but like if you're trying to appeal
to them like on a human standpoint
because like obviously saying you're
wrong or like you're not you know you're
you're dumb stuff like that isn't gonna
appeal to them it's just gonna irritate
them so like maybe trying to go about
like uh Democrats coming from a
standpoint of you know I'm sorry that
these politicians have manipulated you
and lied to you to steal you know to
take your vote for their own personal
power and greed I like that idea and
then like present like actual real life
how it would affect like Democratic
policies would affect your daily life
not just these two broad or too
anecdotal versions of these scenarios I
totally understand the idea I think it's
a good one but understand that a lot of
these folks aren't going to want to
accept that they were tricked and lied
to but your instinct is a good one your
instinct is not to just start beating
people over the head with facts Hannah I
gotta run but I really appreciate the
call
yeah thank you all right Hannah from
Georgia that does it for calls today we
will take calls again I promise you that
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the Friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpackman.com we sometimes will
include Facebook posts or messages or
YouTube comments or tweets or it's all
fair game if you're commenting publicly
but info davidpackman.com is the place
to email we are starting today indeed
with a YouTube comment it comes from
Robert Robert says my president Trump my
president who I voted for who took care
of America first left an economy with a
1.4 percent inflation everybody was
working then on the first day like I
told everybody I studied this I already
knew the election was going to be stolen
he's going to shut down the Keystone
power plant gas is going to go up he's
going to open the Border this country is
self-destructive everything happen it's
self-engineered it's all intentional and
you know that and then there's more but
I would be very very much oxygen
deprived if I continued
uh
it's gonna be hard to talk this guy out
of this stuff at Thanksgiving okay that
that I can say for sure
and uh this type of stuff is everywhere
it's quite literally everywhere I don't
know what we do with it
I don't know how we deal with it and we
recently spoke to former Scientologist
Mike rinder
who said oh no no no cult beliefs are
they are very very stubborn things they
are very resistant to change I guess we
would say
uh good luck to Robert
a Dan Rhoden
and uh again this one of the things that
happens is when we do a live stream lots
of people who have no clue who I am or
about our show will be watching
which is great thanks to the algorithm
you know new people but many of them are
shocked that I'm on the left and I don't
just shut my mouth the entire show and
Dan wrote in about the Abrams dab eight
that's d-a-b-a-t-e and said packaman
I was trying to hear and understand the
viewpoints being espoused tonight but
due to your unnecessary Progressive
commenting I decided to change the
channel and not even give Abrams a
chance right
my opinions made it so that you decided
that you were supporting Brian Kemp
incredible amount of power that I have
Dan goes on to say I think that your
viewpoints are poisonous and not
indicative of most Americans not really
accurate actually
yes I am with Trump and garbage like
transgender should not be taught in
schools again I still what does it mean
to teach transgender I don't know
they're all repeating it I pray that
your children will have a more
conservative viewpoint on subjects that
are internal to homes and not society as
a whole
no prayer needed
uh I think it is quite likely that my
children will have beautiful
uh empathetic open-minded perspectives
not very much aligned with Dan
but thank you and yes if you just want
the debate only there are many many
other places where you can find that
ozan wrote In
with tears in his eyes he says did Mike
pillow ever send you pillows to try out
I heard their normal pillows nothing
special also are you going to appear on
his insane show I seem to remember him
inviting Yuan while he was arguing with
your Facebook followers love the show
yeah so
no on the pillows pillow insisted during
the interview I'm going to send you
these pillows you could they're going to
be the best thing ever
and I said listen I think you're
completely wrong about voter fraud but
if the pillow's a good pillow I'll tell
the audience and he said his assistant
would follow up his assistant never
followed up no one followed up there are
no pillows on the way he also did not
invite me onto his show so it may make
him as a shock to some of you
he may not always be telling the truth
I'm starting to suspect Daniel wrote in
about Tulsi gabbard and this is a this
is a good question
David at what point do you think Tulsi
gabbard started plotting out her Dem
exit her Democratic exit I do have to
admit I was Bamboozled by her although I
didn't vote for her of course you're
right and in hindsight I see she was and
is obviously a grifter
I just wonder if as far back as 2016 or
before she had already been planning
this that she had been positioning
herself to be a Democrat who would
ultimately leave the left because the
left left her after all that's how the
right-wing pundits have used her showing
her off as a Democrat who they can
depend on to criticize other Democrats
much the way they did with Dave Rubin
both of them took advantage of that to
position themselves for financial gain
and notoriety before ultimately becoming
full-throated right-wingers what do you
think Daniel in San Francisco I do not
think this was something Tulsi planned
ahead of time
tool C is an opportunist and a grifter
okay and as such I mean guys think about
it I understand going from you know I
really think we should have super high
taxes on the rich to saying actually I
think 37 as a top tax rate is fine once
you make above 400k even if you make a
billion bucks like I can understand that
I don't agree with it but I can
understand that but tools you went from
being a Democrat by name anyway in the
Democratic primary
two over the weekend she was a a rally
to end child mutilation and of course
your guess is as good as mine what that
means does that relate to vaccines does
that relate to gender affirming care for
Trans people I don't I don't know what
child mutilation they're referring to
but it's a whacked out event
it's just opportunism it's where who's
interested in me Democrats were not
interested in Tulsi she got what one two
percent of support in 2020 in the
primary and just nobody cared because it
was also boring same thing with Trump
right I mean listen if Trump did his
shtick and said I'm running in the
Democratic primary haha maybe he makes
one debate and then he's gone Trump's
not winning a Democratic primary it's
the wrong audience for him he needs
people willing to you know so he ran as
a Republican similarly
the stuff tools he's doing works way
better on the right and she's going full
in so no I think she did not plan this
far ahead it was just when she ran in
Hawaii the way to become a member of
Congress was run as a Democrat
and I think Tulsi if anything probably
has very flexible political views or
none at all and it's just all a grift
Bill wrote in and says David I have a
question can Trump run in 2024 that is
the 22nd Amendment says no one can be
president who's been elected twice Trump
won in 2016 and he claims he won 2020.
therefore the fact he refuses to concede
the 2020 election means he can outrun in
2024. bill of course you're making sense
but no this isn't going to work because
they've already figured it out this way
and I'll tell you it is they are right
about this
even if you believe
that the will of the people was for
Trump to win
the states transmitted their electoral
votes such that Biden got 270 and Biden
is the president so certainly Trump can
still serve and and I know that I get
the idea right Trump says I ran twice I
won twice well if you won twice you
can't run again
you can't serve more than two terms as
president and Trump has only served one
term so I wouldn't I wouldn't focus on
that too too much Kevin wrote in and
says hey uh David first off I watched
your recent video showing the absolute
Insanity of these right-wing political
hopefuls how these people have gotten
this far is beyond me second do you
think these people pronounce Kamala
Harris's name as Kamala instead of
Kamala because it sounds more Brown for
lack of a better clarifying term it
seems to me they have a vested interest
in making their opponents seem more
other regardless if they turn around and
spit out Melting Pot disingenuity right
after
uh thanks for your show David yeah I
mean listen
I'm not saying Republicans in their
heads go hey you know what
if I say Kamala instead of Kamala it
sounds more black so I'm gonna do it
I'm not even necessarily saying
Republicans think to themselves I'm
going to disrespect Kamala Harris by
mispronouncing her complicated non-white
sounding name I think it may even be
operating at a subconscious level but
there is no doubt
that part of the reason they can't just
say Kamala or won't say Kamala
is because Kamala Harris is a non-white
woman
subconsciously overtly we could argue I
don't know but there is no doubt that
that is a factor
mayank wrote in about the Gish gallop
and says David sir you spoke about how
to combat the Mike Lindell style Gish
Gallup debate strategy which was super
interesting it made me wonder if you
have any tips on how to learn to deploy
that strategy in a debate yourself I
also wonder what happens if both parties
use that strategy incoherence I assume
yeah so as a reminder Gish Gallop is
when
you you say 10 12 different things in a
debate uh it's impossible to follow all
of them it's just like throwing a bunch
of crap at the wall right so you know
during these 2022 debates we've seen the
topic of I don't even know the southern
border come up right and a republican
will go
uh Joe Biden has opened the southern
border and is letting people pour in to
these Democrat Sanctuary cities the
Border was fixed under Trump the wall
was built and we had the strongest
border ever and they're bringing in
fentanyl actually they like to say
fentanol fantanal the fentanyl is coming
in from China
and it's coming through the southern
border and now it's in Halloween candy
right and
if it's not oh you get 30 seconds to
rebut that right if you get 30 seconds
to to rebut that the way many of these
debates are structured you can't do it
the debates are mostly structured in a
way where you can't fight the Gish
Gallop the best way to have a fighting
chance when you have 30 seconds to rebut
all of that stuff
to say listen
there were so many lies there I can't
rebut them all in 30 seconds if you give
me more time I will but the wall wasn't
built there is no open border the
fentanyl right and you just go boom boom
boom boom boom
he he or she is lying to you that's your
best shot in a 30-second response format
in a more
extended conversation at Thanksgiving or
whatever
what I like to do is say listen
you just mentioned 12 different things
we can't talk about 12 different things
at once we just we just can't
are you willing to to talk about these
things one at a time so we can actually
figure out what's going on because I
want to know what's really going on
and if you can get the other person to
commit to that
um then you have a fighting chance but
in the debate format it's impossible
because you can't do it in 30 seconds a
Malcolm wrote in and said this is why
Democrats lose
hey David I watched your excellent
stream of the Georgia Senate debate
there was a difference of expectations
Warnock proving he should continue as
U.S senator Walker proving he could
express coherent thought in the English
language I waited for Warnock to deliver
the killing blow he let Walker Express
pro-life sentiments without bringing up
the abortions he has paid for and let
him take a stand on many issues he
doesn't understand or has no answer to
from crime to health care to education
why do you think mainstream Democrats
can't fight Republicans on their own
level I don't want them to dismantle
democracy or perpetuate lies but I do
want them to fight Republicans on their
own ground by fighting hard can we fix
this I was also disappointed so on the
abortion thing I think Warnock just said
he considers Walker's personal life in
the abortion stuff
out of bounds so I think what Warnock
decided not to talk about that but there
were many opportunities for Warnock to
say ladies and gentlemen my opponent has
no idea what he's talking about he just
said about a hundred words there is no
meaning to what he is talking about
here's the truth about ABC if he can't
even explain to you that he understands
this how can we Empower him to be one of
100 U.S senators it is dangerous ladies
and gentlemen the Republicans have done
something dangerous and disresp
irresponsible here he didn't he didn't
go that way I don't know why and maybe
his thought is it would come off poorly
I I don't know why but I was not
thrilled with that performance or many
others Mark Kelly's performance wasn't
good uh it's depressing and I'm sure
there's an explanation as to why
I'd like to hear it and evaluate it for
myself we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com don't miss it
thank you